marine partaud joueuse de tennis
professionnelle qu'elles sont 18e
françaises et 380 10e mondial bonsoir
marine partaud merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous alors on fait tout à fait
transparent vous nous y avait autorisé
vous êtes vacciné vous n'êtes pas
spécialement contre cette vaccination
tout comme d'ailleurs novak djokovic si
vous avez eu vous même le covin malgré
votre prudence ce soir le numéro un
mondial de tennis est toujours sous la
menace d'une expulsion c'est une affaire
politique trop médiatisé quel est votre
sentiment de deux sportives
mais c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
parce que voilà nous on voyage
énormément
provac soin anti vaccin va pas débattre
sur le sujet après nous on est on est
obligé de se faire vacciner vis-à-vis
des voyages là moi je suis actuellement
aux etats-unis et si jamais j'étais pas
vacciné je n'aurais pas pu venir ici
donc voilà après c'est vrai que
l'australie a mis en place une politique
extrêmement strictes et ce que je
comprends parce que voilà ça a été
l'état où ils ont été plus confiné
l'année dernière donc voilà je comprends
que les habitants il ya un petit peu de
frustration de leur part est d'avoir un
passe droit pour novak djokovic
oui et non parce que ben voilà il est nu
rang mondial d'accord mais moi je
connais une joueuse qui a été renvoyée
chez elle elle était simplement dans le
tableau double est exactement dans la
même situation que djokovic est l on en
n'a pas du tout parlé donc derrière tout
ça je pense qu'il ya un souci aussi des
kits et voilà c'est ça devient
très politique est effectivement au
niveau des gouvernements entre eux pour
une histoire comme comme novak djokovic
alors je sais pas s'il va pouvoir jouer
l'open d'australie mais c'est vrai que
tout ça prend une ampleur médiatique est
assez énorme et c'est vrai qu'il peut
comme ce genre de situations y avoir
voilà des choses peut-être qu'ils
interrogent en avaient vite qu'il dit
comme vous d'ailleurs
vous avez le coc vig lui aussi dit il je
n'ai donc pas me faire vacciner même si
voilà il ya des doutes en tout cas selon
les autorités australiennes sur se passe
la date de ce passe mais ça veut dire
qu'on doit se faire vacciner ayant eu le
coc vite ça n'a pas été simple j'imagine
pour vous prendre cette décision
également
oui tout à fait et surtout comme bon à
la base j'étais pas non plus une pro vax
voilà j'avais plutôt envie qui est un
petit peu plus de recul sur sur tous
âges estimé que voilà c'est les tests
expérimentaux n'avait pas été fait dans
les temps impartis donkova je n'étais
pas forcément pour le vaccin mais encore
une fois j'ai pas forcément une fois
vis-à-vis de des tournois des
déplacements après ce qui est un peu
contradictoire c'est que on arrive quand
même sur les tournois même en étant
doublement vacciner on a quand même des
tests pcr a montré à l'arrivée on a des
tests pcr durant les tournois après les
tournois pour pouvoir voyager à nouveau
donc c'est vrai que voilà on est
doublement maxime et tout toutefois on
doit quand même présenter des tests pcr
et oui moi je ressentis effectivement
les effets après le vaccin que ça après
le coc vide ou après le vaccin lui-même
voilà pendant pendant plusieurs semaines
j'ai eu du mal à l'entraînement j'ai des
difficultés respiratoires plus que
puisque d'habitude donc je comprends
certains d'athlètes qui soit qu'il soit
vraiment réticents dont novak djokovic
parce que oui ça impacte notre corps et
et nous effectivement on est un sportif
de haut niveau c'est d'autres outils
travail au quotidien c'est vrai que
voilà par définition un athlète n'est
pas le commun des mortels dans son
rapport avec son corps ça c'est quelque
chose qui pour vous n'a pas été
adapté par les les lois alors on va
parler de la france puisque nous sommes
en france il ya une spécificité tout de
même vous le dites c'est votre outil de
travail le régime n'est pas du tout le
même et on sent peut-être voilà certains
peut-être effet ça n'a pas les mêmes
conséquences pour vous comme pour
quelqu'un d'autre peut-être
oui oui tout à fait je me suis bien
renseigné auprès de mon médecin voilà
après avoir eu ma première ma deuxième
injection savoir quelles étaient les
préconisations à prendre en tant que
sportif de haut niveau parce que
effectivement on pousse notre corps à
l'extrême sans cesse donc voilà ça va
pas être un footing du dimanche entre
rim et qu'on va aller faire si on doit
aller s'entraîner ça va être cinq heures
par jour donc si notre corps est déjà
affaibli par un virus ou par par le
vaccin qu'il est en train de lutter
contre quelque chose on le sait très
bien dans un état normal où on est
malade etc on va pas forcer sur notre
corps nous ça va être
froid 10 entre guillemets donc donc
c'est vrai qu'il faut être vraiment
vigilant est ce qu'il ya une vigilance à
importante de la part des autorités
vis-à-vis des sportifs de haut niveau
concernant le vaccin je ne sais pas mais
en tout cas nous et moi en tout cas
personnellement je sais que ça m'affecte
voilà j'ai eu ma deuxième dose courant
décembre et et j'ai comme on recommence
juste à récupérer mes capacités
respiratoires sur le court aérobic en
fitness etc donc donc c'est compliqué
aujourd'hui on imagine que vous échangez
entre athlètes il ya d'ailleurs les jeux
olympiques de pékin qui s'annonce il ya
une inquiétude durant ces temps de
pandémie pour les athètes parce qu'on
parle du vaccin mais enfin on parle
évidemment aussi du duc o vite parce que
attraper le coc vite pour un athlète on
imagine qu'il peut y avoir là encore des
conséquences assez désastreuse et y
compris à long terme peut-être parfois
oui quitte à fait moi quand j'ai attrapé
le coc vide pendant deux mois j'étais
out je pouvais pas m'entraîner enfin
j'essaie de m'entraîner mais vraiment
sur le terrain j'étais complètement
fatigué après je suis parti en tournoi
mais voilà ça a été très compliqué aussi
mais surtout nous entre guillemets en
tant que sport individuel où
voilà moi si je si je joue pas tournoi
si je les une rentrée d'argent
donc un moment donné si ça nous pénalise
pendant deux mois va voir ça va être
deux mois de salaires qui vont être
coupés et aucune rentrée d'argent
derrière ça donc c'est vrai qu'il ya des
conséquences économiques aussi et qu'il
faut pas négliger et et au delà du fait
que oui ça nous atteint sur le plan
physiologique
il ya de réelles retombées économiques
derrière qui sont qui sont compliquées
pour les joueurs de second rang comme
moi évidemment comme novak djokovic a
n'a pas forcément l'impact et en termes
économiques mais il faut pas oublier
tous ceux qui sont derrière rossi et qui
sont aussi impactés par ce qu vide à la
même échelle que que les tout meilleurs
et on imagine en vain on espère en tout
cas qu'en 2025 atteint les jo à paris
cette pandémie sera bien derrière nous
marine pardo ma part tout pardon merci
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et bonne chance à bout pour vos
prochaines compétitions merci à vous